みなさんよろしくお願いします頑張りと申します
皆さんこの話皆さんのお楽しみいただいてますでしょうか
ちょっとねお昼からずっと見ていて疲れちゃったって方もいらっしゃるかもしれないの
でちょっとね話をする前にそれしましょうかっていうわけでじゃあちょっと僕と同じ
ことやっていただきたいと思います
まず両手を前に出して
ってゆっくりかるーく上下にさーさーさーそうなゆっくりですよ
さあこれで怪しい集団の出来上がり
ね今入ってきた方からじゃあなんだこの集団と思う方もしれませんけどじゃあもう1回
点をまっすぐ伸ばしてそしたら両手を内側に90度回転を蛇が選挙で勝つ
そしたらどちら向けでもいい増え上に上げて
手を交差させてそして解けを合わせます握る
うっ
そして親指を期待ます
青系できますねさて国家できますちょっと大変
ここから横に親指をぐっと思っていますどちらもできる公でいいです
そして歳暮も90度上に持ってきてゆっくり開いてやって
はいリラックス終了ということでへちなみに俺ができた方
僕に言うとおりやってませんさあこんな感じで始めてきたいと思うのでよろしくお願い
ます
いやーにしてもねキョウ者様だったり教授の先生だったり
懐プレイヤーだったりまあいろんな方がいらっしゃってなんか一人すごい浮いている
感じなんですけれども
でも実は猫のレッツにフィークというこのテーマにおいてマジックっていい題材だなと
思いました
と言いますのもうこれマジックの励起子につながるんですけどもちょっと簡単に入れ
ますねマジックの励起子をご紹介させていきます
実はマジックってね that 5000年くらい前から始まっていますつまり世界4
大文明ができた頃か
ただ当時は今僕がねこう皆さんに産むんですような感じでエンターテインメントとし
合ってたわけじゃないです
呪術ですとかおまじないまあそういう占いですかそういったねちょっとほか
ルトロジックなものに使われて
そしてそれを使うことによってその国の政治ですとかといったも支配していたと日本だ
と例えば邪馬台国の卑弥呼とかまあそういうのが有名だと思うんですけれども
そんな感じでねマジシャンはフェ
正常化に世界を表から裏からやっているということになります
ただしはい当時のですね
まあマジシャンはそのマジックの秘密をですね
人も教えなかったのですまあ当たり前ですねそれをやっちゃったら
自分が持っていたその力がなくなってしまうね他の人もできちゃったら
を区別がなくなっちゃうので
そうなのでいいしそうでに自分の子供孫
さらにそのシーズン伝えたいですとかれ死をとって想定しだけに教えるとそういう方法
をとっていました
そしてまあ
自動化にで多分あっていいかわけなんですけれどもそっからしばらく中世ヨーロッパの
じゃあになるとですね
あるべき事が起こります
皆さん魔女が入ってきたございます
ねっ
昔はですね
まずのマジックの要素っていうのはですね尊敬に値するものですけれども中世になると
それが恐怖の大勝だったんです
なのでそういうマジックが使える人間は魔女だね
悪魔の使いやといて捉えて拷問にかけたりですとか
火あぶりしたいとか
そういう形にできることがあったんですけれども当然のことは僕のマジシャンもう普通
の人間です
ね何か特別なあって糞って何が起こるわけじゃないです
なのである本が出版されました
それが世界で一番初めてたマジックのやり方教えているコンっ
その本によってで僕たちがあっては妖術の類じゃないんですか
訓練次第で誰にでもできるものなんですとアピールしてそしてまあそういう魔女狩り
から池田と
さあそしてだんだんだんだんマジックというのが広まってきて徐々に徐々に
エンターテインメントの
ネタても音楽出るとかそういう
演劇0とかそういったもの
一つに肩を並べるようになりまあ今にやると
これがねざっくりとしたマジこの駅になりますこれ細かく説明ショートしたらあと2
時間くらいかかるんですけれどもそれはそれだね長いと思うのでこのぐらいに置きます
酒でで
で今僕たちマジシャンはいろんなマジかっています例えばトランプを使ったマジック
ですかこういうを買っちゃう
大がかりな箱の中に女の一人で切ってしまったりとか
やるんですけれどもそういったものの多くはですね昔の
それこそ先ほど言いました何千年前からアイデアが出ています
例えばええ
大一番最古のまでクリーますと約5000年前
エジプトリー文明が出たこと
ファラオと呼ばれる王様がいていろんな人たちましたけれどもマジシャンとねそういう
子術師の人はどんなことをしたかというと例えばステップ
その杖を一瞬でコブラ2階ですか
もしくはナイル川の中に手を入れて
そのまま殺菌用はそんなジョーな時にですね
をサラサラの状態に取り出しあげたとか
そういったことをやってみました
そのアイディアが今も僕は師マジシャンを使っているんです
もちろんね使っている道具猫ぐらいに書いたりもしません時差金を使うわけではない
ですけれどもそういうアイディアを昔からね
受け継いできていると
さあ今 a deep を半焼しましたけれどもエジプトに紅発散ムラットにムラが
あります
そこの音動物にある壁画があるんです
これべき初弾壁画とかでね警察を出てくるんですけれども
なんかでコップのようなものを
まぁそこを上にして何かやっているようなで会がありです
これが世界最古のマジックと呼ばれているんです
っていうわけでまずねそれをねちょっとお見せしたいと思います
避け使うのが
はいっ
まずカップポップですね1個
nikko そして3個3つあります
ただねちょっと今これケーブル高さの関係は見づらい方はこの後ろの画面とかを見て
頂ければと思います
それとを使いますのが
パンッ
当然金パンリオは食べ物だったりとか石ころを使ってやっていたんじゃないかと思うん
です
ちょっとちぎってやっ
おいています
さあここからねマジックと言いますかちょっとさゲームです
pop をひっくり返します
入れる
をクリッ
さあここから
今パンはどこに入ってるでしょ
まあなんかはい
正解ねっところなんで前半ボケちゃいましょうか
じゃあここからね
ちょっと難しくしました
なので1個がきちんとこの中にはない
さあということでこちらとこちらはい
サードポジション
ポッチッ
まずこっちは
ってことはこっち日でもなくてこっちですねはい
アレハレべます
たあたあたあ母じゃあもう
もう一杯でしょうかじゃあもったいね
今度はちょっともうちょっとちぎってやって
あ
またこのままねー
おいてやってちょっとパンク度とって
いきましょうここから
ん
こんな感じでいいかな
マキコって持って行って
これ
おっ
そして最後このまま
カップの中に入っ
あれべます
サステイ
いただきますということでね palmer ちゃんと処理しますので大丈夫ですけど
あっ
ちょっとケーブルをきれいに仕上げてこんな感じですね
マジックが行われていたんじゃないかとまあ言われています
ひょっとしたらこれはただのギャンブルだったかも知れませんで何可視化の実施だった
かもしれないんですけれども
んだねー
8版を飲み込んだので
ここからこのマジックを現代版にアレンジしたものを見せします
もちろん昔あるものをそのままやるだけだとただのコピーでしかありません
そうするとやっぱりねそのテクノロジーテクニックの進化というものはどの業界でも
そうである
ありえません
なのでここからちょっと今のバージョンの面白いものをお見せしたいと思いますので
ちょっとお客様どなたかお願いがあります
お金がてください
いませんお札を大媽してくださる方いらっしゃるでしょうか
どちらの1判1列目のお嬢さんありがとういます助かります
こちらお里は何でもいいですあの千円札五千円札1枚立つもしくは海外の金でも構い
ません
ありますあそんなに調子がある僕ね今までこれた腐っていたんだけど札束で押されたの
初めてですは
だ大きなお札を1枚を選んでください
はい魔ってこれどこもお金
あってトナメ ok ですじゃあさらにですねじゃあもう1回をで際お願い者にて
よろしいですか
ちょっと者一旦こちら声来ていただいて
はいじゃあねーはい2じゃなくてここにねシールがありこのシールに入っ
どれでもいいので1枚さんにしてください
はい
すごいなぁ
あったがねぇ
僕マジシャン歴15年なんですよね初めてですわね
はいじゃあ1枚サインしていただいたらそのサイン車シールをこのを割くのどこでも
いいので貼っちゃってください
これ残りは回収
入れます変回収してもよろしいですかはい s 無線
あるいますさあじゃあとしたらここから
今ねこれなんでサインしてもらってシールを張ったかと言いますと
こう言ってね
たたんでいきますかちょっとで真ん中だとあれなんでちょっとずらっしゃいますけれど
も
でしょうこの味
あとでお返しした時にこれが本当に自分のかどうか証明するため
もちろんねこれなかなか日本髪なおかつなんでまぁ偽物とかないと思いますけど燃料に
俺
捨てたたんじゃるこうすると畳みながらでもこのシールのサインがちょっと見えるので
自分のなってわかると思うんです
そしてもう一つ
神かいます
この紙で包んだ
ねちょっと者すいません紋章をお願いしますちょっとここ触っていただいてちょっとお
客の感触ありますよね
つけても見えるしホッケーがそうしたねもう一個使うものがありまして
新ただ一杯たーーー
あげました以上で
i パンダーなあかんが5秒下
だとしたら8年まぁこれだけだとねちょっとしたあの大問題になってしまいますので
じゃあせっかくなんでちょっとこういう花で特別なものをお作りしてお渡ししたいと
思います
お酒飲めますか
あちょっと特製カクテルをね作ってたてあげようかなと思うんですけれども
じゃあよかったよねその代金ということで先ほどのお金はいただきたいと思います
たというわけでちゃ音楽にをしてみましょうお願いします
彼がいますのは数名
dj で去っ派
ヘタの上ください
三方五いいかもしれませんテイカーするモータースポーツ2つ3つのパートに分かれ
それと歌うのがいい
ポールぞ
晴れ達成
たっきりです
飾磨港一帯持って行って叩いてやると
ただしん
さあも行きたい持って頂いちゃってたい所だ
love ボイ
まあ低下に立ち向かった真ん中なんですけども山北クロレラの警戒など
ん
ありません
んだー方とから
me
酒井そうするとはー
あっありがとうございました
ben
を叩いて言ってるのでません
[音楽]
続いて火災木遣そう
明日ただこれだと多い約詰まっ感出てきたパークっています
ボールもちゃっていいですか
ran
だから
曜日ごと中に入れていてマイナス生
ただいくという
ああああああ
もう+このためます
暇ってやつでワンツーですこれで
持っています
ちょっと入りますがっはっはー
て今度はコレット
ran
me
これを言っていますね
タブを開けますよ日本いますねええええマンデルかっ
1見られてって
とって
[音楽]
ハロプロバッハ
car
だんだん日が本当まいりましたので買ったらええええ
どうかって加藤グラスバー
tan
me
ok
いいといい
はいいいえ
さあ皆さんほどたちました本日のそれから飼ってる
キャベツでございますん
me
細かいちょっと1個の表彰入りません
この買っている
恋愛を始めたです
[音楽]
me
ええええええ
amaran
[音楽]
なんか融合なります
単車にこちらが最高度ファン言っていただいたお札であることをご確認ください
カーカーとこんな感情楽しみ頂きましたビタミン c 豊富にしておきました
言いません日本へ葉っぱですねあてぃましたけれども
bouvet ありません
どんなアーレやっぱり母コープ見直してどんどん良いバーフラッシャー大事なんだと
思いますよこれ以上で僕の交
終わりたいと思いますおはようございましたはぁ
私ます
[拍手]